新幹線でところさーん全然違ったダークにスティングレーを東京の新居に連れて行こう
と思ったんですけども
う
メッシっ
だけでしたダメが原因としてはモノとしては大きすぎるので新幹線に乗らない人では
ないのでひと月分払ってこいつ尾崎に乗せることができなかったのでこいつを公共交通
機関で東京まで持てるのはもう無理だところが判断しました
9分
新幹線は無理バスも無理郵送しましょうみたいな話もあったんですけどそれダメです
生き物ですからだけでも生きているので彼をそんな輸送することができませどうしたら
僕はこいつをなんとか東京に持って行けるのかと考えたところ
ヒッチハイクしかないと思いました今朝でフォーンとすぐ東京に行くんですけども
ヒッチハイクをしてなんとか何とかこの私と
ダークネスに爪を東京に連れて行く人がいないかと信じて僕の家から東京まではなんと
か父俳句をして誰かに乗せてって言ってもらいたいと思いますちょっと大事なキャップ
です
無事届きれることを願いますがまろ
か地図を日から東京への道なりで誰でもいるなるべく東京に近づけるように順番に乗っ
ていければいいなと思っております
良い人がいれば一番いいんですけどねばかり sa やつやってこれでうまいことも
東京に連れていってくれればいいなと思っております
俺はこいつに
に場所を与えたい行くぞ兵庫産何が何でも絶対投票に届きます絶対東京都
今絶対東京に連れて行きます
待ってるあそう起用
みなさまがんばってこのダークネーションウェット僕を載せてくれ車をちょっと待って
みようと思います
ああああああ
紅葉
えっ
止まってくれたんだけど止まってくれた止まってくれた
あれねーっ
piso 者
何してる sao
yeah
adele うわあああああ
これでは末恐れを
えっ
えっなんでいいのはなんでいいのよーじゃったこの辺にマッシュ減俸にこと死ぬ岡田吉
増加
こいつをした東京まで連れて行きたいんだけど東京に来てんっ
r も結局いくんあいけど帰りなんですよ
じゃあ乗せてもらっていい有様ぜ行っちゃっ
ブーバーし
言うなるんだね今やらなきゃ行けないかなあだよね
このまま東京に向かっておりますません
止めて唸るギャルズ付ガードすればいい
ありがとうマジでいい
はぁぁっ減っていっ
いや場所はどういう状況なんだぜ
参ってねーまいりましたね僕は仕事でおかえりでございます
東京の空気をおいしいと思ってますかネタってますよ顔色悪いよね減っちゃいましょう
してるありがとうございますよ愛が続いて別
この家にピソ一生ありがとう本当ここはたぴゅっ
4助けてねお世話一発いい
ああああああああ
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo てきたわー
熱湯で無事ダークネス犬で東京水質完了しました
これで結構にわかりやすくなると思います静岡にいる時がたプロ the
東京にいるときはダンテに水分にちょっと見てもらえればわかりやすいかなと思います